good news today in the fight against the  coronavirus this morning drug company  moderna announced it's going to ask for  emergency fda approval to start making  its vaccine public in december  this comes as more than 4 million people  tested positive for covet 19 in november  that's more than double any other month  since the pandemic began in march  top american health officials put on a  united front sunday  with a blunt assessment of what comes  next  we may see a surge upon a surge we are  deeply worried about what could happen  post thanksgiving  it's going to get worse over the next  several weeks  last week 24 states set new coronavirus  case records  the u.s is seeing about 180 000 new  cases every day  modernist says the fda will likely meet  it to discuss  the request for emergency use  authorization that meeting expected to  be december 17th  the elderly and healthcare workers are  expected to get any new vaccine first